where did you leave the tail of Epstein
well I think he had been arrested I
think he had just been arrested yeah
now if you were too bright Oh God if you
were to write a a brad thore novel okay
how do you think this would how what do
you think might have happened oh I'm
gonna say something very twisted go
ahead but everything's twisted
everything's twisted he got gang-raped
in jail or something or now he he he
hung himself in jail now I say it's dead
he's dead he's dead now here's the deal
he tried to commit suicide okay the
reason why I say hung I do believe he
hung himself
but melisten to this listen to this so
he tries to commit suicide they put him
on suicide watch they move him to this
institution where the cameras are on him
24/7 every 30 minutes someone has to go
and check on him they don't even have
sheets they have paper sheets okay so
you have it is for people who are high
profile high risk okay it is the
lockdown of all lockdowns like Hannibal
Lecter yeah okay he hangs himself with
paper sheets could be done can it be
done yeah I think it could be yeah I I
do believe that he hung himself but what
makes it hard to believe but is there
video but you would think so but the
video cameras they haven't said why but
the video cameras that were on his cell
not anybody else but on his cell
malfunctioned both of them and every 30
minutes they have to go and check on him
but those two guards both fell asleep
and why are you telling me you believe
this because I want to have hope hope
you know because it could have been
Trump or Clinton that had him killed I
mean there's a million
people including the Queen wanted that
guy dead yeah now here's another reason
that you might not believe it his
partner that was the model agency chief
okay right like the guy that was like
finding the girls
yeah and was the head of the modeling
agency okay he's just disappeared they
don't know where he is every bit of him
has been erased off the internet no cell
phones no nothing online that he's ever
done all erased and he's gone
no one can find him when I was leaving
Candace's wedding in Virginia Virginia's
really lovely I was by Monticello I'm
sure you've been there a million times
and it's incredible Jefferson's estate I
saw a little cabin it's sort of very far
off the thing and I thought that would
be nice to live there I mean what that I
mean that's insane that's me I mean look
the guy was evil I mean he was truly if
anything they're saying about the guy
was true this was a truly evil to me
they died you know it looks it looks
that doesn't strike me as the story
anymore no the story is evil this is not
the story you know and now everything's
just kind of going away I mean this guy
had more on people and I believe I
believe he may have killed himself
because he knew once he's released into
general pop what could happen to him
what you said and what his life was
gonna be like I do believe that that
that is a big motivating factor if
somebody wanted to kill the other guy
disappearing the other guy disappearing
the two cameras not working the guards
were asleep this is hearing it hearing
that all that right there it's like
that's exactly I'm talking about about
why why I pray that the media could
actually yes reconstitute itself because
you have to yeah because wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be your greatest joy
basically short of like you know
something with your kids or your wife or
whatever but your greatest joy to be
like do you know that an honest decent
media good people started to rise up and
now when something insane happens where
you're you can go down that conspiracy
road forever right like that sounds far
more realistic some crazy conspiracy
theory then
some guys fell asleep at the camera went
out mm-hmm but because we don't really
have enough trust in any of these things
any Bubba effect yeah that's the Bubba
effect there's a and I didn't I didn't
plan on talking about this but you can't
believe your eyes anymore there was a
video of a deep fake and I can't
remember who it was anybody remember who
this was gonna be the next thing the
deep fakes oh my gosh was I here well
the last time I was here I think maybe I
talked to you I know I talked to Ben
Shapiro last time I was here about
technology and what's coming nobody knew
what a deep fake was you know three
years ago I'm telling you it we are now
at the point now at the point to where
you cannot believe your eyes I can't
nobody yeah well it's all I've seen the
videos we're done with Obama and it yeah
like something you cannot tell now you
cannot tell last week there was the
first AI voice-recognition break-in so
some CEO had a voice code and it was
broken into by AI that reek created his
voice they broke in stole all of the
stuff and that's again what I'm saying
about the speed we just you know cept
all of these new things in our life and
I'm not you know it's funny because I'm
not an anti technologist by any stretch
I love this like people in Silicon
Valley they don't let their own unions
have it they don't use it
have you seen that that there's a still
image of Zuckerberg from like five years
ago where they think somebody took a
picture of him standing at his desk and
he has his webcam covered by a TV and no
audio think of right tape and it's like
wait and you don't let your kids on this
and Steve Jobs didn't let his kids on
right it doesn't Bill Gates not let his
kids on social media what do you know
that we don't what do you guys been
doing but we all keep doing it again I
include myself in this and that's why I
want I really I'm really going to try in
the next year to use whatever influence
I have to really try to to just I can't
reverse it and I don't think nothing can
be reversed everything moves forward you
don't but to want to stop the growth of
Technology but we have to stop and think
think
I'm doing a show tomorrow on radio about
this new technology I think it's BCI and
it is now on with Zuckerberg Zuckerberg
and musk are working on it they say now
that through your neurons they have an
algorithm that can actually take your
neurons and place them into words so now
whatever you're thinking lovely right
and so musk is saying we have to have a
new bill of rights of privacy that your
brain is your brain your thoughts are
your thoughts and no one has a right to
take them they can also alter them with
this technology how frightening is that
pretty sure there was a book written
about thoughtcrime yeah and I think
we're I think we're veering we're
veering into all of this stuff and okay
let me give you three bad things that
happen oh that wasn't the bad stuff no I
wasn't that bad this is this is the
stuff that really kind of matters right
after you went on vacation we had
shooting in Dayton Ohio killed 10
injured 27 let me just tell you I'm not
gonna use the name of the guy but this
is how he is described demented he had a
chilling Journal of demented scribbling
and satanic drawings spoke of hunting
someone at the University of Dayton seek
and destroy it said he was very ADHD
paranoid schizophrenic strong bolt
bipolar he ranted about drugs violence
and women referring to them as
even being dissatisfied by his own looks
they his friends said that he was
smoking methamphetamines all the time
when they were hanging out
he thought Donald Trump was a bad guy or
a dumb guy but didn't like Hillary
Clinton either what do you think the
what do you think the narrative was on
shooting number one
well obviously gun control
said this is gonna be gun control we
never have the conversation about mental
health which is correct we're supposed
to have those gun control in the
atmosphere that Donald Trump has done
was it wasn't the Matt no it wasn't the
math and it wasn't the the psychiatric
problems that apparently you know I'm
guessing he wasn't a member of the NRA
no he he was not the member of the NRA
then we had another shooting that
happened thirteen hours later this one
happened in El Paso Texas and Donald
Trump was immediately condemned because
the media said his manifesto talked
about illegal immigrants okay and how
they were invading the country so for
two days we had Fox News stopped using
the word invade on the air okay
but I want to read his manifesto because
a we never read manifestos I never do
but this one is important to correct the
record you tell me who's responsible my
ideology has not changed for several
years my opinions on automation
immigration and the rest predate Trump
and his campaign for president I'm
putting this here because some people
will blame the president or certain
presidential candidates for the attack
but this is not the case the then goes
on talks about the need for universal
basic income for universal health care
and he ends like this the American
lifestyle affords our citizens an
incredible quality of life however our
lifestyle is destroying the environment
and our country the decimation of the
environment is creating a massive burden
for future generations corporations are
heading to the destruction of our
environment by shamelessly over
harvesting our resources this has been a
problem for decades brilliantly
portrayed in the decades-old classic The
Lorax watersheds around the country
especially agriculture arrows being
depleted freshwater polluted from
farming and oil drilling he goes on and
on and on he ends it with this I just
want to say that I love the people of
this country but goddamn most of y'all
are just too stubborn to change your
lifestyle so I guess the next logical
step
is to decrease the number of people in
America using resources if we can just
get enough rid of enough people that our
way of life can be sustainable does that
sound like a trump supporter to you
[Music]